it's Britain's oldest travel company
operating in more than a dozen countries
with 19 million customers a year but
Thomas Cook struggled to be profitable
despite a 1 billion dollar injection of
cash earlier this year the company said
on Friday it needed an additional 250
million dollars to stave off collapse
bad news for the 600,000 people around
the world on Thomas Cook holidays when
word spread about the dire financial
situation this hotel in Tunisia briefly
refused to let holidaymakers leave
demanding money afraid that they
wouldn't get paid if the company went
bankrupt lévêque oz shisha PE I paid
more than $2,000 for the holiday they
want more than what I paid I told them
I'm not responsible for Thomas Cook
firstly it's kind of blackmail if you
pay it you don't leave the British
government is promising to help anyone
stuck abroad I can reassure people that
in the worst-case scenario the
contingency planning is there to avoid
people being stranded more than a
million people around the world have
holidays booked with Thomas cook if the
company goes bust there is little danger
they will lose their money thanks to
various consumer protection schemes
Thomas Cook is seen as the inventor of
the modern day package holiday a cabinet
maker from Yorkshire he was a strong
supporter of the temperance movement and
believed travel would help Britain's
refrain from drinking alcohol he started
out by arranging day trips by train in
the 1840s the excursions proved so
popular that within 20 years he was
selling tours to continental Europe the
Middle East and the United States but
the modern day company has been under
intense financial pressure rescued from
near bankruptcy eight years ago and how
people book their holidays has added to
the company's plight high street travel
shops have been facing stiff competition
from the internet and while package
holidays like those from Thomas Cook
often provide good value many consumers
are now shopping around online booking
their accommodation and flights
separately to create a bespoke travel
experience
despite being a mainstay in the British
travel industry analysts say the company
struggled to compete
Thomas Cook is a marvelous brand it has
an incredible heritage but I'm afraid in
the 21st century in the ferocious
competition of the travel industry that
counts for nothing
all that matters is do you have a
profitable business and sadly in the
case of Thomas Cook we know the answer
is no a 178 year old business steeped in
history but apparently failing to keep
up with modern times catherine Stancil
al jazeera London